you strike out you resign
so many characters in zootopia sound so
familiar right well it's not surprising
as they're voiced by
major hollywood stars disney's 2016
movie has a large group of
seriously talented individuals voicing
its animal cast
from oscar winners to world famous
singers and even a disney princess
yes really join us as we take you behind
the voices to discover
who's who gosh think of the headline
we're starting off with the fox that
forms one half of zootopia's central
double act
nick wilde you might know this american
actor from his work on arrested
development or maybe you recognize his
voice from his more recent work
directing and starring in the netflix
crime drama ozar perhaps it's his other
film credits that you're familiar with
starring alongside the likes of jennifer
aniston in horrible bosses huh you got
it yet that's right
nick is voiced by jason bateman the
movie's directors byron howard and rich
moore said
it's so distinctively jason but in a
whole new way
it's a perfect role for him and he
brings all the dry wit and attitude that
perfectly jars with the other main
character
sly fox dumb bunny where would nick be
without judy hopps
zootopia's first bunny cop brings a big
dose of much
needed optimism to nick's world and the
voice actor behind judy
actually shares that optimistic outlook
she's an american actor known for her
starring role in the hbo drama big love
and in the abc fantasy once upon a time
she's got plenty of film credits to her
name too including 2005's the musical
biopic
walk the line and 2009's rom-com he's
just not that into you
this actor also has experience voicing
disney animated characters
having lent her voice to fawn and
tinkerbell and the legend of the
neverbeast have you guessed already
it's jennifer goodwin both judy and i
are
fiercely optimistic someone very close
to jennifer voiced a small part in the
movie too
stay tuned to discover more guys i've
been working for this my whole life
judy comes up against some resistance
from chief bogo
head of the zootopia police department
this tough buffalo with 2
000 pounds of attitude needs a big voice
to match and he certainly got that
the english actor behind chief bogo is
best known for his tv roles and hbo's
the wire
and the bbc's luther plus movies like
american gangster and star trek beyond
and franchises such as thor and the
avengers
as well as voicing sheer khan in the
live-action jungle book and fluke in
finding dory
this actor has also taken on such
important parts as nelson mandela in the
2013 movie mandela long walk to freedom
we know that you're shouting at your
screen now yep it's idris elba
this is an opportunity to do something
it's funny did you
shake your thang to gazelle's tune try
everything in zootopia
if you love the pop star's voice then
it's probably no surprise that a
world-renowned singer stepped up to the
mic to play the part of the gazelle
and she also wrote that song especially
for the movie she's got such a
distinctive singing voice but
did you manage to figure out who she is
we've got one more clue for you
this spanish-speaking performer voices
gazelle in the spanish dubs too
you've probably worked out by now that
we're talking about shakira the awesome
colombian singer-songwriter
we love officer clawhauser's description
of gazelle are you familiar with gazelle
greatest singer of our lifetime angel
with horns
speaking of officer clawhauser who
doesn't love the zootopia police
department's most adorable cheetah his
love of donuts and gazelle
and his enthusiastic attitude must make
him a delight to voice
and the actor behind benjamin
clawhauser's voice has been in a fair
few tv shows
including the fox sitcom weird loners
and the hbo series hello ladies
if that doesn't ring any bells you might
recognize his voice from his adwords he
played a credit card customer
representative alongside david spade in
capital one's what's in your wallet
campaign his other commercials include
enterprise rent-a-car
volkswagen goldengrams and nfl.com
the man behind the cheetah is nate
torrance
oh m goodness they really did hire a
bunny
zootopia has a huge cast of characters
some of whom only have a couple of lines
case in point priscilla the three-toed
sloth who is flash's co-worker at the
dmv
in fact she only has two words but the
filmmakers managed
to get a big star to do it the actor
that voices priscilla is no stranger to
disney movies
in fact she's the voice behind one of
the studio's most famous characters of
recent years
and the casting director managed to get
this actor on board because she revealed
on the ellen show that she loves sloths
she explained how her husband got a
sloth to come to her birthday party and
she was
immediately overcome that's right it's
anna from frozen
yeah yeah kristen bell when she got
offered the part she said yes within a
couple of minutes
they describe it as the quickest deal
ever made in hollywood
yes flash
that small time crook's name is a big
giveaway as to who voices the weasel in
zootopia
duke weaselton is a reference to the
duke of weaselton from frozen and the
same actor voices both roles
he's no stranger to disney animated
movies also voicing the parts of high
high in moana
knows more and ralph breaks the internet
and alistair cray in big hero 6.
do you know the actor's name it's alan
tudyk in a fun easter egg the bootleg
dvds that duke sells
includes version of these very same
movies wreck-it rhino pig hero 6
meow wanna and float zen 2 you might
also recognize his voice as the droid
k2so in rogue one a star wars story
it's weaselton duke weaselton and i
ain't talking rabbit
some characters in the movie have a
really distinctive voice
and the lamb bellwether is certainly one
of those if you're familiar with the
actor's work
then having such a standout voice should
make it easier to figure out who's
behind the assistant mayor
in fact it's thanks to her idiosyncratic
voice that she got a role in the
animated sitcom bob's burgers she's an
snl alumnus that landed a recurring role
in the tv show parks and recreation
house of lies and kroll show but her
breakout role was in the 2014 movie
obvious child
since zootopia she is lent her voice to
gidget in the secret life of pets
and harley quinn in the lego batman
movie we're talking
about jenny slate playing bellwether was
a dream come true for jenny
us little guys really need to stick
together right
of course we can't cover the assistant
mayor without moving straight on to the
actual mayor of zootopia mayor lionheart
the actor behind the mayor's voice has a
long list of
impressive credits to his name his tv
work includes law and order
oz the closer and counterpart and as for
movies he starred in the spider-man
trilogy
plus 2014's whiplash which won him a
whole lot of awards
then there's his voice work in gravity
falls kung fu panda 3 and various marvel
animations
ready for our reveal the man in question
is jk simmons
he's spoken about how great it is to see
the range of your voice coming out in a
fantastical character
okay officer hopps let's see those teeth
the list of big stars go on with an
academy award-winning actor providing
the voice of mrs otterton
the rival otter whose husband emmett had
gone missing she might be a tiny animal
but she's got a huge star as her voice
let's drop a few clues so you can make
your guesses this american actress has
not only won an oscar but also a golden
globe and screen actors guild awards
although she made her film debut in 1996
her breakthrough role came in the 2011
movie the help following other acclaimed
film roles she's turned
to tv with the truth be told on apple tv
and
self made on netflix we probably had you
at the help but if you're still not sure
we can reveal it's octavia spencer
since zootopia octavia has also voiced
another animated character
corey the manticore in the 2020 disney
and pixar movie onward
please there's got to be somebody to
find my image
if you're a fan of pixar animated movies
then you'll probably recognize the voice
of bonnie hopps judy's mom the actor has
starred in no less
than eight pixars in fact zootopia was
her first
non-pixar animated film although she's
only got a small part in zootopia she's
got a recognizable voice
let's run through a few of her other
roles so you can get that light bulb
moment she voiced rosie in a bug's life
ms flint and monsters inc karen graves
and monsters university
sally carrera in the cars trilogy and
dolly in toy story 3 and 4. you might
actually have seen her acting in movies
like beethoven
jumanji cheaper by the dozen jerry
maguire and the green mile
the actor we're talking about is bonnie
hunt total coincidence by the way that
she shares the same name
and we're just a little excited for you
but terrified
on the subject of prolific voice actors
the person behind jerry jumbo jr has
lent his vocal skills to many characters
over the years
so it would make sense that you'd
recognize the voice of the bad tempered
elephant who owns the ice cream parlor
the actor has been in so many animations
that it's impossible to list them all
here so we'll stick with his best known
parts
that's bender on futurama jake the dog
on adventure time
dr drakken on kim possible scotsman on
samurai jack
brother blood on teen titans schnitzel
on chowder
hammerhead and sandman on the
spectacular spiderman aquaman
on batman the brave and the bold and
king zog on the netflix series
disenchantment
it's john dimaggio we reserve the right
to refuse service
to anyone mr big is also played by a
veteran voice artist
this arctic shrew is the most feared
crime boss in tundratown he's got a band
of polar bears at his beck and call
but although the voice actor has used
his skills for many characters on screen
you might not recognize him from his
rendition of mr big that's because he
does a mafia style voice that is not in
keeping with his other roles this
canadian actor has something in common
with john dimaggio he's worked on
futurama
in fact he's voiced a variety of
characters on the mac graining animation
he's also the voice of brain
in animaniacs and the spin-off pinky and
the brain plus egon spangler in the
animated real ghostbusters tv series the
man we're talking about is maurice la
marsh
i will take your kindness and pay it
forward
yaks the yak is one of the best bit
parts in zootopia who can forget judy's
shock when she realizes yaks isn't
wearing any clothes and his response
we're a naturalist club the canadian
american actor who voices yaks is just
perfect for the role
after all he's a cannabis rights
activist and is known for his marijuana
theme to chichen chong comedy albums and
movies with cheech marin
you might also know him from that 70s
show it's tommy chong
told you nangi has the mind like a steel
trap we're finishing up with a fun fact
remember how we mentioned that someone
close to jennifer goodwin also gave
their voice to a character in the movie
well now it's time to reveal the details
the character is the frantic pig who
owns the flora and fauna flower shop
that duke weaselton robs
he comes rushing out onto the street
screaming at judy to do something
the american actor behind the voice is
best known for his tv work in the abc
series once upon a time
and the nbc drama manifest he also
starred in the marvel comics film
adaptation thor
and he happens to be jennifer goodwin's
husband that's right josh
dallas lent his voice to the frantic pig
it's so funny to watch the couple
screaming at each other in different
sound booths
well are you a cop or not oh yes yes
which voice behind the character
surprised you the most which zootopia
character
is your favorite let us know in the
comments and hit that subscribe button
for more videos from the things
thanks for watching
you